[Music]
so our philosophy is that what we would
like to see in the standard rather than
describing the solution for Oh hammer
what we would like to see is describing
extensibility mechanisms that companies
hardware vendors can implement their
favorite form of mitigations that one
that works best for their particular
type of memory by leveraging these
extensions you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using dynamic
random access memory or DRAM it's the
most popular form of volatile computer
memory in the world but it's
particularly susceptible to ro hammer an
adversarial attack that can cause data
loss and security exploits in everything
from smartphones to the cloud today dr.
Stefan Sirois who is senior principal
researcher in MSRs mobility and
networking group explains why DRAM
remains vulnerable to ro hammer attacks
even after several years of mitigation
efforts and then tells us how a new
approach involving bespoke extensibility
mechanisms for DRAM might finally have a
ro hammer and the fight to keep data
safe and secure that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Stephan's Arroyo welcome to the podcast
Thank You great Chinese great to be here
some of my favorite people on the planet
are working on making things work for us
and you're one of those people so first
thanks as we begin though let's talk
about your people for a minute you're a
senior principal researcher in the
mobility and networking group which
isn't totally separate from systems and
networking but they're not totally the
same either so give us a verbal Venn
diagram of the two groups why they exist
where they're different where they
overlap and how in broad strokes each of
them is working to make our lives better
yes thank you for the kind words
Gretchen so back in the day Microsoft
Research had a single systems and
networking group and as the group got
larger the group split into several
smaller groups like the Systems Group
the security group the distributed
systems group and the mobility and
networking group but we're all systems
researcher at the end of the day whether
we work on operating systems on networks
on mobile systems or on distributed
systems so I'm part of the mobility and
networking group but over my research
career my work has focused on systems
both in terms of mobile systems and
networking systems and for the past
couple of years these systems that I've
been working on aim to improve the
security of users in the security of
infrastructure let's get specific and
talk about the work you do within the
mobility and networking group now so
sort of in general what big problems are
you trying to solve as a researcher and
and maybe more importantly why does the
world need you to solve them what gets
you up in the morning so I took two
kinds of work the first kind is creative
work because I really value creativity
very highly and I believe it's very
difficult to come up with a truly
creative idea the second kind of work
that I do is driven by intellectual
curiosity and by revisiting assumptions
or turning them on their head and I
strongly believe that the role of an
expert is to break preconceived
assumptions and rules unfortunately you
have to be an expert first in fact
trying to break assumptions before
understanding deeply an area and a
problem is a very
idea so I've been working on a secure
systems research for almost a decade now
we built a secure Network tracing system
that offers very strong privacy so for
example network operators can monitor
their networks in a way that all the
sensitive data is locked down without
anybody being able to subvert it or use
it in any way other than originally
intended
we built sensor that can attest that
information is correct and has not been
manipulated or changed so as a simple
example consider a photo where one can
check whether the photo has been
photoshopped or is indeed captured by a
proper camera then I worked on a secure
payment system called zero for payments
that was a little like the precursor of
Amazon ghost or so our system was a
little different in that you'd pick up
the food in your daughter or cashier who
drink you up but you'd not have to do
any explicit thing to actually pay the
system will know who you are and since
you'd have to pre register with the
system and the payment would be
processed so I've worked on all these
things I've also worked on a firmware
TPM which brings trusted computing to
mobile devices and it works in millions
of smartphone and tablets today but for
the past couple of years I've worked on
Azure security in particular and we
started a project called project stem ax
stem a stands for secure trustworthy and
enhanced memory Frazer and we've been
focusing a lock on ro hammer attacks
well let's talk about memory and
computer memory specifically since
that's the foundational storage unit for
digital data but there are many kinds of
containers as you well know so let's do
a quick primer for the flavor that we're
really most interested in today which is
DRAM so how does it work physically what
are its vulnerabilities both internally
and externally and you don't need to get
ridiculously granular here cuz I saw
your 114 page deck and 100 pages of it
is explaining deira no I'm kidding
don't be afraid to get as technical as
you need to set the problem up okay so
DRAM is the world's most popular form of
volatile memory pretty much every form
of computing out there has DRAM you can
find around in smartphones in tablets in
PC
you can find the ramming cars you can
find the ramming washing machines and
DRAM cell stores as your oh one and it
does that by using a very simple circuit
with one capacitor and the capacitor can
be charged or discharged and that can
mean a 1 or a 0 so for example if you
wanna store the value 1 0 1 0 you just
sort of have 4 cells and you have 1
charge capacitor 1 discharge capacitor 1
charge and one discharge and you encode
1 0 1 0 that way now capacitors leaked
over time they sort of lose their charge
over time so DRAM has to continuously
refresh these capacitors and the cells
are built to maintain their charge for a
small period of time say something like
64 milliseconds and the contract is that
the hardware has to make sure that every
single cell in its DRAM it's refreshed
once within 64 milliseconds and in that
way the cell maintains its it's data is
charged now DRAM cells are organized in
rows and columns and when you read a
value from DRAM you read by row and the
way you read this is by switching some
transistors in such a way that the
capacitors are then coupled with some
sensors so the sensor sends whether
these capacitors are charged or
discharged and then they can translate
that into data now unfortunately what's
happening is that when you actually
sense the data and the capacitors it
turns out that rows located in the
vicinity in the adjacency of this row
you're trying to read those capacitors
also get affected and it get affected by
having them discharged faster than
normal and this phenomenon is called a
DRAM disturbance error because by
causing them to discharge faster within
a 64 millisecond period you lose the
content of that cell and in some sense
the bit flips that way and the bit that
flips is one that you never actually
meant to read there our access before
maybe you don't even have control over
it maybe some other software component
that controls it and so that's where
sort of the concern lies in the theorem
space there is this row hammer attack
and the contract from day one when you
build any system any software system
anything you want any computer the
contract is that if you give me a piece
of memory when I write something to it I
want to be able to read what I wrote and
with row hammer you violate this very
simple contract you read a different
value than the one you wrote and doing
that you can basically exploit systems
in ways that are unimaginable before
well since we're talking about row
hammer right now let's move into it as
you put it once it's one of the hottest
research topics in the security research
community so give us a level set what is
row hammer specifically and why
particularly does it make cloud
providers and server farmers nervous so
I describe this drm disturbance errors
effect and this effect gets worse as
DRAM gets denser and denser and we want
the alarm to get denser and denser
because that's how we store more
capacity that is how we battled better
the RAM but the phenomenon gets worse
this theorem disturbance error a row
hammer attack it's an attack in which an
adversary generates a workload that
exploits disturbance errors to flip the
value of bits that have critical
importance to the security of the system
like for example bits that form a secret
key and code vendors are very nervous
because the entire business model is one
where you have multiple parties share
your hardware in particular in this case
they share your memory or they share
your DRAM well what if one of these
customers becomes rogue they themselves
get exploited to some other attack can
they attack other customers by flipping
bits in their memory and yes they can
attack it in very devastating ways how
did ro hammer get its name is it because
of the rows in the DRAM I was explaining
how when you access a row an adjacent
row gets affected by that and the attack
in order to create this disturbance
error what you have to do you have to
keep accessing that
over and over and over again and that's
the term hammering there oh and yet that
tag got this name ro hammer so if I'm an
attacker am i trying to do something
specific or am I just trying to mess you
up
oh that's a great question depends right
so it was a cloud provider the cloud
providers are nervous about both
scenarios a row hammer attacking general
refers to flipping a security critical
bets so by flipping that bit I'm trying
to target something specifically I'm
trying to exploit something
however the simpler and in fact that
like clear form of attack is one where
I'm just messing up the bits and systems
actually today in the cloud they're
pretty good at detecting when these bits
are messed up but if the bits are messed
up there is just very little you can do
about that I see these bits and I've
encoded enough redundancy in the data to
know that they're messed up but I can't
recover to where I was before and there
is really not a good way to solve that
problem once the bits have flipped it's
like I can go back and the best thing I
can hope for is maybe you reboot the
server and let's start all over again
and that's also very very bad for a
cloud customer because there are a lot
of workloads in the cloud I have a lot
of data in memory they do a lot of
computation maybe they train a machine
learning model and then you know for
many many days and at some point you say
well sorry guys you have to start all
over again because we've messed it up
[Music]
before we dive into the technical
aspects of your research on the row
hammer threat I find this the whole
drama really fascinating and I think it
would be good to set the stage and the
cast of characters we've talked about
cloud providers who are the other
players who provides to the providers
and what's their motivation who sets in
guards the standards and finally who's
got an eye on everybody it's a
fascinating landscape Microsoft is a
cloud provider and I started with cloud
providers because part of our role and
Microsoft research is also to make the
cloud better there are several other
players and one big players are the
companies that sell DRM and when the
attack was first described or published
which was in 2014 the hardware vendors
jumped too quickly dismiss these
concerns means we knew about a hammer
but that's a problem that that older
type of memory has the newer type of
memory it doesn't have this problem
anymore and I in fact there are quotes
online where vendors claimed that ddr4
which is the memory that we all use
today is row hammer free and of course
researchers have shown over and over
again that ddr4 is not row hammer free
and then they said oh yes but then you
should buy these newer ddr4 that has a
form of Defense called trr and just this
year earlier there was a wonderful paper
from an academic group in the
Netherlands that showed a huge number of
ddr4 DRAM with this form of Defence TRR
being vulnerable by slightly changing
the form of the attack okay so basically
what the vendors have done is they've
patched the old way of mounting the
attack but they haven't told anyone how
they patched it and you just have to
sort of try different things until one
of the new things clicks and then you
can bypass those defenses so now we have
the cloud providers the DRM vendors and
then the security research community and
there is this feeling loop where the
dinner vendors say up yeah we knew about
it the new memory safe give it a year or
two the security researcher me says oh
it's not safe and sort of the cloud
provider is in the smartphone
manufacturers as well are caught in the
middle
so ro hammer is a problem it's a big one
and it hasn't been ignored but hasn't
been solved either so when we talked
before you said that more than 40 papers
have been published on this subject and
DRM still remains as vulnerable as ever
so what is the academic community done
to date to try to solve the ro Hammer
problem and what today they got right
and got wrong right so there are sort of
two bodies of work in academia one is
the security research community and then
there is a computer architecture
community and to give them credit
actually the computer architecture
community we're the first ones to show
this problem to sort of raise the flag
saying hey we have a DRM disturbance
error and the architecture community has
been very good at putting forward a
whole bunch of ro hammer mitigation
proposals however all these proposals
did come with trade-offs and
implementing one of these mitigations
inside of DRM will make that DRM
ultimately more expensive in some way
maybe it will decrease the density maybe
the different vendors will have to add
extra memory or extra sort of counters
to keep track of who's accessing what
and the market forces in the DRM world
are in such a way that they need to use
every single piece of real estate they
have to just cram more and more cells
and that's where the security research
community comes in where they keep sort
of reverse engineering and trying
different things and they found ways to
go around those mitigations and show new
forms of attack so to refer to them it's
sort of also a business thing like I
said people knew about row hammer and
there were discussions in there sort of
standardization body that is an
organization called J deck where a lot
of hardware vendors and software
companies actually participate there's
been a lot of discussion over the years
on implementing a solution and in fact
that's what they're doing now there
won't be a single solution for row
hammer that will work for every single
type of memory out there and for which
every single hardware vendor will be
willing to actually implement so our
philosophy is that what we would like to
see in the standard rather than
describing it the solution for all
what we would like to see is describing
extensibility mechanisms that companies
or hardware vendors can implement their
favorite form of mitigations that one
that works best for their particular
type of memory by leveraging these
extensions so that's what we're trying
to sort of change and shift in light of
all that stuff and tell us about your
most recent work that involves what you
called an end to end methodology to help
cloud providers determine if they're
susceptible to row hammer because that's
an upstream approach that you're talking
about instead of the patch afterwards
that's impossible so in the context of
our cast of characters and against the
backdrop of computer memory solutions
that have trust issues tell us how you
are attacking this what your methodology
is how successful it is and what are the
key challenges that you face so what we
try to do is we try to help the software
company by building a systematic and
scalable testing methodology to test
whether your DRAM is susceptible to a
row hammer attack and to build such a
methodology you have to overcome two
practical challenges you have to devise
a sequence of instructions that your
processor executes that hammers the
memory but the fastest possible rate you
want to create what we call the
worst-case testing conditions from
memory the second thing you want to do
you want to know where you're hammering
remember I was telling you how DRAM
disturbance occurs two rows that are
adjacent to the roller you're hammering
well the rows that are adjacent are the
worst-affected but even rows that are
nearby are effective so a row that sort
of two rows away like the next neighbor
or something like that can be affected
but it's very difficult to affect the
road that's very far somewhere inside of
your array so you have to actually know
what is the row by row layout of your
DRAM chip and this is in fact the trade
secret what we did was we built a
hardware fault injector that allows us
to you can think of it like
short-circuiting the memory in such a
way that we can actually always create
this row hammer attack
by not letting the memory refresh itself
so if you hammer a row in the memory
never refreshes you're gonna flip bits
eventually because then the capacitors
will look their charge and then you go
and study the patterns of how these bits
have flipped and that tells you about
the layout of the cells inside of the
DRAM because guess what the row you
hammered most of the bits that flipped
are going to be in into JSON rows and
there will be some bits flipped in that
next to the adjacent rows and then fewer
bits and so on so we create these kind
of heat maps so you can reverse really
row by row adjacency by this form of
short-circuiting the memory of
suppressing refresh commands okay so
your reverse engineering to find out
what's going on yes we have a
methodology our methodology can reverse
engineer every single ddr4 dimm in the
world and which actually end up
discovering when you reverse engineering
is that these maps change they change
from one vendor to another and then can
also change from one team to another
depending on the team's revision it's
called post packaging repair so we can
actually also measure how many fixes
that DRAM has had before it was shipped
to you okay so this methodology has to
attack for lack of a better word yes yes
every vendors particular proprietary
chip and within the vendors there's
different chips as well so you've got a
lot of things you have to be looking at
how's it working so far wow that's a
great question
it's very difficult to test every single
chip that a cloud provider has so
instead what we're doing is we are
mapping the DRAM fabrication process for
different DRAM devices and for different
vendors and then within those buckets we
sample and we test and we actually what
we do we look at the trends and they
want to make sure that the workloads
that we see in the cloud will not
generate activations that will actually
start flipping back saying because I was
telling you the DRM gets worse over time
not better so in fact we can even by
waving our hands a little bit we can
predict how many years in the future
it's gonna be until we're gonna see
workloads reach a point where just by
using
memory they're gonna start flipping bit
and it's our job to influence sort of a
more principled approach to fixing the
problem rather than a band-aid approach
and also to keep an eye not just for
Microsoft with the entire cloud industry
as - at which point we'll have to do
something to make sure that the
workloads are not gonna actually start
causing bit flips so for example one of
the things you might want to do when you
actually detect that a virtual machine
starts accessing the memory in a way
that might actually induce bit flips you
could try to slow it down or migrate it
to a new dram or or do something like
that yeah so there's more solutions than
just fixing the chip right other
mitigations in fact i think the
solutions will have to spend the entire
stack there will be some fixing the chip
things but those freaking the chips have
to sort of be programmed or used by
things higher up mode by the CPU and by
the software well that leads well into
the next question there's a lot of
people that need to be involved in this
so tell us a little bit about who you're
working with as partners and what kinds
of cooperative expertise do you need to
solve for X in the system security
equation
none of these works I've been describing
is mine alone and in Microsoft Research
I've worked with a small team of very
talented people who have expertise that
is very very different than mine you
know I come from a computer science
background and I am not sort of equipped
to short circuit memory or anything like
that and in fact until a couple of years
ago I really didn't understand how DRM
works very well so we have that sort of
expertise in Microsoft research to
basically build Hardware prototypes that
actually can inject this sort of
failures into the hardware into the
memory okay and then I also collaborate
very strongly with a group of wonderful
engineers in Azure there is a group
called the next cloud system
architecture or NCSA and these folks
have decades of expertise of
understanding how DRM works and working
with JTAC and working with the memory
vendors and they've been very good in
two ways one was in describing to us
how memory works in ways that go beyond
what the manual can teach you and sort
of what the concerns are than the
limitations that the forces that act see
when you actually build these circuits
in practice and the second way that
they've been very helpful was that when
we interact with JTAC and we try to sort
of make this shift they've been very
good at coaching us on how to put
forward that proposal in a way that's
more amenable who are your other kind of
big partnership associations are you
working with other academics are you
working with other industry are you
working with other cloud providers we're
lucky that we have very strong
collaborations with two top academic
places one is ETH Zurich and the other
one is at Max Planck in Germany and we
are working closely with companies that
can be massively affected by row hammer
when security researchers actually go
and start to find a new way to actually
attack the memory they go through a
process that's called responsible
disclosure so what that means is that
they will not make their findings
publicly available but instead they're
gonna reach out to all the industry
involved and describe their findings and
give some time to the industry to form a
response and once this period has ended
then the research becomes public so when
these new forms of attacks came about
there was a group of company formed that
started looking at these problems again
and the first thing that they had on
their mind is like look you know so we
have these research results but can
anybody go and independently validate
them on their hardware so we at projects
Temma were the first to actually
validate these findings on server grade
hardware hardware that is run in the
data centers right well it sounds like
you all have the same goals you don't
want things to break you want things to
work well ultimately you want customers
to have safe data and things not to
break we do and in fact I was mentioning
how for row hammer and for testing
memory understanding row by row
adjacency is very very important and I
also said how DRAM vendors do not want
to reveal this information okay in fact
the extensibility mechanisms we proposed
for people to build their own forms of
rock hammer mitigations from the
beginning we design them in a way where
theorem vendors do not have to tell
anyone
these adjacency maps in fact there is a
large swath of row hammer mitigations
that people have proposed over the past
five or six years that all rest on the
assumption that the software company
will have complete access to this
information and these companies are very
reluctant so rather than mandating that
or forcing them to do something they
don't want to do instead we designed
this with the assumption that hey you
guys don't have to tell us anything and
we think that this have a much better
likelihood of being adopted in practice
and then again not mandating the
solution letting people build their
favorite solution for the kind of
hardware they want to use you know the
raw hammer solution that you built for
the DRAM in a server running in Azure is
very very different than the raw hammer
solution that you should build for an
IOT device that has a little bit of DRAM
and runs a little bit of code
[Music]
[Applause]
we reached the what could possibly go
wrong
segment of the podcast where I ask all
my guests what keeps them up at night so
despite the fact that the majority of
your work could actually be classified
as a research response to what keeps us
all up at night sometimes the so-called
solutions actually present new problems
so do many concerns about the work
you're doing and if so how are you
addressing them my concern is I was
telling you how we have this Hardware
out there whether it's DRM where the
CPUs whether it is you know chipsets
whether GPUs so on and so forth and this
harder it's very very complex and one of
the things that we've learned is that in
the quest of higher performance we have
designed this Hardware in ways that can
be exploitable and these exploits are
done in such a way that we never thought
possible before and what keeps me up at
night is I don't really understand
everything that's going on in add around
device what if there is another way out
there that you can actually mount these
attacks in very very simple ways and
unfortunately with a cloud and with the
consolidation of the entire computing
power into data centers I'm concerned
that we might have an invent that wipes
out an entire cloud that wipes out you
know a big part of our infrastructure
that shuts down the entire internet and
you know we're gonna have exploits and
little things here and there we've
always had those we're gonna continue to
have them but we really never had a
single wipe out event so having a wipe
out event would be quite quite
concerning so how are you thinking about
that as a researcher I mean is one of
those giant problems do you think I
can't possibly solve this but are there
any strategies that come into your head
given the kind of work you do that say
hey this is how we might try to mitigate
such an event it's a very hard problem
you're absolutely right my part comes
when it's about DRM because I understand
Iran better than many people and my
part is to make sure that there won't be
a wipeout event happening because of the
RAM from the point of view of DRAM I
hope that my work plays a role in that
it's a beautiful way to frame it Stefan
because as you point out there's many
fronts in this war against you know
people that are working to keep things
safe and securing people that are
working to tear things down so you say
hey at least on my watch the DRAM part
is going to be good that's right I love
that well I don't want to let you go
before we talk a little bit about
industry standards and the tension
between gatekeepers and practitioners in
a time when technical innovation is
moving so fast that regulatory bodies
have a hard time keeping up so what are
the key challenges to organizations like
jtech in your field and how would you
frame the role of these kinds of
gatekeepers in the future so the
industry is changing at a fantastic pace
and the role of jtech was actually to
standardize how memory is used at least
let's talk about the RAM they actually
standardize things other than DRAM but
DRAM is a big part of it and in the 80s
and in the 90s we needed that because we
were building pcs and we had a massive
number of stakeholders of people who are
actually building all sorts of hardware
components and you wanted these hardware
components when you put them in a box to
all work together now there is a little
less of that there is more of data
centers and there is no need for the
computers that Google put in their data
centers to make sure they work with the
computers that Microsoft was in their
data centers all they have to do is to
offer a software platform that is common
enough that people can actually use it
but because we see this consolidation I
believe there is less of a need for
standardization happening because if a
call provider buys memory from three
different vendors all four parties can
agree on how they built that hardware
and using their data center so I believe
we're gonna see an increasing amount of
fragmentation that way well so what is
an organization like jtech have to do to
stay alive
I think jada has to shift the way they
view themselves as a specification of
what the functionality over the hardware
is to
that specifies mechanisms that are
flexible enough to allow increasing
amount of innovation from the different
stakeholders in place well every
researcher has a unique life story and
it's time to hear yours but I want to
preface this by noting that you've gone
to the trouble of including what I would
call a scholarly genealogy on your
personal website so we can trace your
academic ancestors back to you on one
side of the family the 17th century so
tell us your story Stefan upon whose
shoulders do you stand both personally
and academically and how did you get
where you are today from where you
started back in your early years you
know when I look at it it feels very
humbling every once in a while I go back
and take a pause to reflect because you
look at those names and you go oh gosh
those are some big shoes to fill I had
the opportunity to work with two
different advisors in my graduate school
and therefore I have two genealogies and
like you said one goes back to the 17th
centuries and include names like Carl
Jacobi and John McCarthy and Jacobi was
mostly known for math in things like
elliptic functions and number theory and
John McCarthy is known for being one of
the founders of AI john student was
Barbara Liskov who just won the Turing
award a couple of years ago and she's
sort of a role model for me so yeah I
feel very very humbled and I and I look
at that periodically to sort of remind
myself as to where the bar is right so
tell us a little bit about you then
you've come into this in the 20th
century and have started to make your
own mark how did you get from A to B I
was born and grew up behind the Iron
Curtain in Bucharest Romania and I was
very lucky to attend a high school that
was very strong academically especially
in mathematics and computer science so
in the late 80s and early 90s I was sort
of studying things like algorithms and
graph theory and programming and
languages and so forth and we also did a
lot of math and in some sense I'm I was
very likely to have this training in
math and computer science but it came at
the cost that I am
at anything else and when I finished
high school my family decided to
immigrate to Canada and they went to
Calgary Alberta and when I got there
Canada had a program where immigrants
who lacked English skills they would be
enrolled in free English as a second
language kind of form of schooling and I
spent three months going to English
school with my mom and dad and my mom
and I were in the same class actually
we're in level three and my dad was in
level one and I remember I remember very
clearly a sort of meeting my dad in the
hallways during lunch and having lunch
together it's yeah this was I was about
19 yeah I was 19 at the time a couple of
years later I went to college at the
University of Waterloo which is a great
school in computer science in Canada and
Waterloo has this wonderful co-op
program where as part of graduating
college you have to actually go to
internships in industry and I was lucky
to do three internships with Microsoft
back in the 90s and and I came to
Seattle and I saw Seattle and when I
when time came to go to graduate school
one of the places I applied to was
University of Washington in Seattle so I
came to you Dobb and once I graduated I
wanted to join academia so I went and
took a job as a professor at the
University of Toronto and at front so I
worked with some fabulous students and
then after a couple of years at Toronto
I kind of started missing the intensity
of the West Coast and thus texting here
one of the things I didn't realize
before leaving Seattle is that West
Coast is really one of the best place on
earth to be a computer scientist because
you meet a lot of people who understand
what you're doing and speak your
language and I talked to some of my
friends and they offered me to come
interview at msri I knew Seattle and I
came and I never left and I had a
wonderful time
what is one interesting thing we might
not know about you maybe it's a
personality trait a defining life moment
and hobby side quest that has impacted
your life or career a lot of computer
science researchers in the u.s. who are
not born here
they came here to do their PhDs but I
came much much earlier and I did not
come with a plan to actually continue my
education or pursue any advanced
education so I have a lot of immigrant
stories and I think a lot of those sort
of have marked the way I think people
had a hard time working with me because
I would insist that we work as hard as
possible and we never have any moment of
relaxation or anything like that and I
really truly believe that that's
actually very detrimental to a
researcher a researcher has to have be a
little bit more balanced and I remember
very clearly Steve Gribble one of my
advisors telling me over and over again
Stephan it's not just about working
harder it's also about working smarter
and it took me a long time to understand
what he meant you have to let time allow
you to have the flow creativity and see
things in ways that maybe others haven't
seen them before as we close I'd like
you to take a shot at painting a picture
of a future world in which you've been
wildly successful at the end of your
career what do you hope to have
accomplished as a scientist and how will
your research have made a difference in
our lives thank you for asking this
question I actually thought about this
and and I'm thinking quite a bit about
it if you had asked me this question ten
years ago
my answer would have been I want to make
sure that my research work is being used
by millions of people and I was very
fortunate to be able to accomplish that
at MSR not just once but maybe a couple
of times so going forward again I see my
role as keeping an eye on making sure
that we avoid a form of a wipeout event
at the very least that exploits some
form of DRM and if you know a decade or
two from now we managed to say hey yeah
you know we've had compromises here and
there but for the most part the internet
worked really well
cloud computing work really well you
know AI work really well then I hope
that at least a little part of that was
due to my work as well Stefan Sirois you
I for one am glad you're doing the job
you're doing thank you for that and
thank you for joining us today on the
podcast thank you and thank you for your
insightful questions questions to learn
more about dr. Stefan Saroyan and the
ongoing fight against brohamer attacks
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]